a stark warning as the biden
administration ends the remain in mexico
policy west virginia's attorney general
saying
this will lead to an increase of illegal
fentanyl pouring over our southern
border
fueling the opioid epidemic west
virginia attorney general patrick
morrissey joins me now sir great to see
you
how devastating is ending remain in
mexico
from keeping fentanyl both out of west
virginia and of course
the rest of the country look we think
it's incredibly dangerous and
we're very worried that we're going to
be seeing a surge of epic proportions
i've been talking a lot to our law
enforcement here in west virginia we
already
had a huge fentanyl problem but now when
you start to move to open borders
and you start to reprioritize resources
toward asylum and
other types of migration you're losing
the ability to really
catch a lot of the illegal drug
trafficking at the borders
at the very time when the mexican drug
cartels are really amping up their
production so
we're worried about it we want the bite
administration to rethink this
otherwise we're going to be in court
it's all about resource management here
are the numbers
cbp fentanyl seizures by fiscal year
that's why you're going to see
2021 leading the screen right there
almost
6500 pounds
fiscal year 2021 you see it has
increased a lot since fiscal year 2018.
how much worse sir do you fear this will
get in fiscal year 2022
well i'm very worried about it for this
reason when the byte administration
issued their announcement to get rid of
the remaining mexico
program they didn't even mention going
after illicit drug trafficking now think
about this for a minute
whenever you think about the uh illegal
immigration problem a lot of people talk
about folks
storming across the border in west
virginia we feel it a different way
we feel it when a lot of the illicit
drug product makes its way
slowly but surely up to detroit through
columbus
into west virginia that's a real problem
so i am very worried about this
i also think it's just they haven't
given much thought
to tackling the drug epidemic in a
holistic manner and
i'm hopeful the by the administration
sees this they reverse course
we also think that they're just not
taking into account the law and that's a
real problem
do you worry it's too late though to
reverse course
no we can't give up on another
generation of west virginians
and americans and when i talk to law
enforcement they tell me that
fentanyl is such an integral part of the
drug supply coming in
i'm not going to let another generation
fall prey to senseless death
and we need the biden administration to
do their job
police the border that's why we have
border patrol they have to adequately
resource it it's a big change in policy
from what we saw with trump
from march 2020 until now you didn't see
a lot of stories about the opioid crisis
that doesn't mean that crisis went away
west virginia attorney general patrick
morrissey we appreciate your insight on
this problem thank you sir
hey thank you so much okay i went to
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not gonna miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now